and what are the benefits of zeolite and is it worth taking or are there other foods, herbs,
minerals that have the same benefits that could be safer or a more affordable option?
So zeolite is really a key later. So there's a difference between a binder and a key later. So a binder
is something in my definition is something that's really going to stay in your gut here, not going to
really absorb a lot of it. You may absorb some but it really does, it's made function in the gut.
Now zeolite functions as a binder because it does bind stuff in the gut. What would it be
the purpose of a binder? So why would you take something that would bind stuff in the gut? So the
purpose of that is when your liver goes, you know, when bad things chemicals flow through your blood
stream. You breathe them in, let's say you get them on your skin, you spill gasoline on you,
you eat something that has chemicals in it and you absorb those. It goes into the blood stream,
circulates around the bloodstream. Eventually goes through the liver and the liver holds it out
through phase one, phase two, and then through phase three detox pathway puts it into bile. It gets
secreted through the bile duct into the gallbladder and then out into the dewanum, hopefully to be
deposited into the toilet for the next bowel movement. Now the problem is is these toxins can dislodge
from the fatty bile and can be reabsorbed and we don't want to do that, especially if person has
issues with constipation and things, they may be reabsorbing a lot of toxins. And so you would
eat things that act as a binder. So from a dietary standpoint, things that would act as a binder
would be indigestible fiber. Well, all fiber would actually act as a binder. Indigestible fiber acts
also as a fuel source to the epithelial cells of the lining that line the intestinal tract could really
be a beneficial fuel for helping those replenish themselves. But fiber can be a binder. So other
things like minerals or humic acid can be binders. There's a Shiite that can be a great binder,
bentonite clay can be a binder. So those are mainly some of those are found in foods but some of those
things are followed in supplements as well. Ziolite can act as a binder too. So the purpose of a binder
again is to grab out of things in the intestines so that you toxins in the intestines so that you
don't reabsorb them so that they get deposited into the toilet. Ziolite also acts like a key
later. So a key later would be something that you absorb and that grabs out of things in your blood
streams or a blood stream or in the tissues and pulls it into the blood stream to then go
through liver phase one phase two phase three and all the way out and get bound in the intestines
in the positive the toilet. So Ziolite acts as a as both of those. So Ziolite can be a good
key later. Now the process of key lading toxins out of your system out of your tissue
sounds like a fantastic idea. Well I should do that because everybody's toxic and boy I should
start taking some key laders. But I highly recommend that you go back and either take my course on the
seven phase detox because you have to know before you start key lading which I call phase zero
as you have to make sure phase one to three four five six is open and working well because if you
start key lading out of the tissues and you have a backup in the liver it's just going to dump that
toxin somewhere else and you've not made yourself any healthier you could actually make yourself much
sicker. So either look at that course it's super cheap to buy the course and start watching that I
think I have several videos of that course on our video site. I think I have multiple blog posts about
that also. So look at seven phases of detox. Just go on our website into the blog and search seven
phases detox or go to our video site and go into the search and type in seven phases of detox. I
also understand since I'm talking about that and reminding me we're having trouble with YouTube
pulling down videos because of quote unquote medical misinformation and this video will probably
pull down because I said something that their AI will pick up and say this is wrong we don't approve it
oh yeah what did I say tonight's bash the AMA or something like that so that's not going to go well
with them. So Dustin who works at Cutters Clinic here and that's a fantastic job.
It's a good plug wasn't it? I tried to tell him last week that he volunteered some other therapy.
He did a fantastic job in putting up our own private video site. So we're tired of getting our YouTube
videos pulled. We're tired of getting our information pulled. We're tired of getting the AMA
bashing us and all this kind of stuff. Well we'll try to go completely private. We've always had
videos on bright beyond and some of the things like that but personally I don't really go to those
channels. We wanted our own video site. So go to that video site. There's links on our website
to the video site and that will help you understand those things. So as far as other options of
these are from zeolite that are more affordable options from a dietary standpoint make sure you
eat a lot of fiber and from just a normal health site perspective you want to make sure that your
detox pathways are open and that has to do with making sure that you're having daily bowel movements
and you know at least one a day it's really clean yourself out that your gallbladder is working
well and you can take supplements for that using hot packs over your gallbladder. Learn
to do coffee animals. One of the best things for your gallbladder, your liver and your detox pathways
and your anxiety and stimulating your parasympathetic system and all sorts of things. So you'll learn
all about that on that course if you do take the seven basic detox course.